a sweet moment with my girl pink she has  proved time and time again that she is a  mama bear first and foremost I mean just  look at what she did at her concert in  Australia when she spotted a heartbroken  fan it was this small sign that caught  the eye of pink at her packed concert  venue the pop star so moved she stopped  her concert and rented out Lea's mother  Debbie was a massive pink fan and was  originally supposed to go to the show  but after she passed away in June her  grieving daughter went with her aunt  Katrina little did the 14 year old know  with cameras rolling her mom's music  idol would walk offstage find her in the  audience and deliver her ultimate wish  [Applause]  and she's like she looks are pretty and  she's just really nice and she's like  everything's gonna be okay and yeah  she's really asleep we spoke to Lee is  not who told us quote I truly believe  her mum orchestrated the whole thing  it was a hug from heaven  [Music]